should I pursue my idea so I got a great
question for my youtube viewers love you
guys
pioneer who wrote in the say grid video
I have a little question about invention
ideas so my career path has being an
environmental engineer I've already done
my degree I'm passionate about it I plan
to do it at full time for the immediate
years to come
however I also have a few invention
ideas that I'm passionate about I
believe a high quality would add some
serious value however these are
completely outside my field my question
is is it worth to pursue these or just
leave them in the idea stage I'd like to
add that the main goal the invention is
not just to make money rather I'm
seeking the satisfaction take one of
ideas making a reality through hard work
if money is there at the end so be it
but I could really care less it's more
about accomplishment than income so
there's a fantastic question and one
that I know a lot of entrepreneurs face
and I can't tell you what to do what
decision to go for but I can give you a
framework to make your decision easier
okay first of all I love your approach
you're doing it for the right reasons
you have an idea you're passionate about
it you're not going to just trying to
make money you're trying to do it to
have the sense of accomplishment and
making people's lives better and that's
why you start a business what I would
consider is if you don't do this idea
now will you regret it will you regret
it will you look back on your life you
fast forward to when you're 70 years old
you look back on your life will you
regret saying you know what I really
wish I had tried that invention idea
instead of just going for my job that's
what I would look at and hopefully that
answers your question this is something
that I went through when I was in
university all through high school I
wanted to be an investment banker it was
in my yearbook I was gonna be a VP at a
major investment bank and I thought I
was gonna be an investment banker and
when I was in university I got offers to
work with Merrill Lynch and McKinsey
Consulting McKinsey consultant was a
huge shoe teacher consulting firm the
number one in their field and Merrill
Lynch is a huge investment bank and they
would fly me around the world and you
know 80 100k starting salary awesome
opportunity
and meantime I had started my business
and I was making a few hundred bucks a
month not able to survive like just
struggling along and I looked at it and
I had to make a decision like what do we
do with my life do I go take this job
that I thought I always wanted or do I
run this business that doesn't seem to
be going anywhere and what help makes
the decision easier was I didn't want to
look back on my life and live in regret
and wonder what if I had tried this
company a little bit more and giving it
my all
and that made the decision easier and I
said you know what I can always go back
how can gonna try it for a year I can
always go back and do this thing again
get the job again that job will still be
there in a year can always we'll find
another job too if my business doesn't
work out but I won't regret turning that
down but I'll regret not having tried my
own business and that made the decision
a lot easier for me and I never went
back and got a job and I'm so grateful
that I didn't this idea of regret
minimization came from Jeff Bezos and
when he started amazon.com I've told
this story few times but he was the
youngest ever VP at a at a major firm
and he left to start amazon.com to sell
books online at a time when online was
nothing and everybody thought it was
crazy like Jeff what are you doing you
the youngest ever VP at this company why
would you leave to start this dot-com
business that nobody cares about nobody
knows anything about and his answer was
I didn't want to live with regret he had
to try it out because he knew that would
haunt him for the rest of his life and
when you talk to people who you see
videos of people were talking about you
know they're on their deathbed they're
looking back on their life and you never
see people regret taking their shot
right
you see people they look back in their
lives and I said they wish they took
more chances and so I don't want that to
be me if I want something if I'm excited
by something I want to be able to go up
and take my shot even if I'm afraid to
do it so I would apply that framework to
you
when you're seven you look back in your
life will you regret not having tried
these ideas if you're like now whatever
like if it works it works if not I don't
care then then you have your answer
don't worry about it go do your job
you're passionate about it your goal
you're golden but if you look back and
you think man I really that was a great
idea I really wish I gave it a shot
because I could always go back and get
another job then do it do it so when you
fast forward your life you don't have
any regrets believe those are watching I
love to hear your stories how did you
make a decision between one option and
another option maybe with a safe option
and the risky option what advice would
you have to give please leave it in the
comments below so other people can be
inspired by your story as well you guys
like this video thumbs up below click on
my face subscribe to the channel thank
you so much I'll see you soon